I think Ruby and rails absolutely lowers
the bar in terms of what it takes to to
get a web application going some people
see that as a negative thing like oh the
barians are at the gate we've got all
these unwashed masses flowing into our
beautiful pristine programming
communities and we're if dates a lot of
times before Visual Basic before that
was chastised for bringing in sort of
unpure programmers I think it's
there is no such thing as the pure
programmer and I think that what's magic
about the Ruby and rails community is
exactly that it attracts people from
from all different camps that attracts
people who are not primarily programmers
I find that often the best ideas come
from people who are not programmers
people who bring just a entirely
different perspective on things in fact
being a newbie is such a important stage
because that's where you question
everything when I first came to to Ruby
I questioned everything it was like why
doesn't this thing exist why is this
hard that's stupid
like we should change that you have this
sort of initial naive approach to things
that makes it impossible for you to see
what should be impossible you just do if
I had known in the beginning how much
work it would have been to actually
create rails I probably would never have
started I started because I just found
one little thing that to my naive newbie
sense seemed easy to do so I think it's
really important that we keep this flow
of new people new blood fresh blood
coming into the community and I also
think it's wonderful that we're creating
a larger group of people who can create
applications trying to have
protectionism
is is never a good idea trying to sort
of set up like this should only be these
carefully trained programmers who are
able to make programs bad that's not how
it should be we should
absolutely have programmers of all kinds
some of these programmers will be new
and they won't know everything and
they'll create shitty programs but you
know what
most of the time a shitty program solves
the problem
you don't need perfect programs all the
time there's so many problems in the
world that the tiny group of pristine
white knight programmers just can't
solve like they can't solve all of them
there's just not enough of them so we
need programmers of all all levels to to
solve the programming problems of the
world
so for me it's really there's two angles
to this there is we can absolutely make
things simpler I think I made a lot of
web development a lot simpler with rails
but there's a natural physical limit
where at the end programming is just
choices how should the program work what
should happen when you click this button
those choices are ultimately what's the
key of programming and you can't get out
of that which is also why I think that
sometimes it's a little bit of a pipe
dream to think that oh there's gonna be
these magical new environments where
somebody who knows nothing about
programming will just be able to drag
and drop a few things into a box and
then voila you will have the most
amazing program in the world no it's
really not gonna happen like that
because to have the most amazing
programmer in the world you need to care
about a thousand decisions and recording
those thousand decisions takes a
programming language so there is a lower
limit to how simple it can get and that
lower limit is you care about these
decisions once you all the decisions you
care about have to be codified somehow
and I don't know of any more effective
way of doing that then then with a great
programming language so I'm not a big
believer that at some point we're all
gonna create these wonderful
applications there'll be a class of
applications where you design a niche
and say okay if I have to just slightly
tailor some accounting software yeah
there can be something simple for that
but if you want a freedom of expression
to create any type of web application
say you need a tool that's expressive
enough to to enable that and that is a
programming language it doesn't get any
simpler than that
[Music]